maintenant qu'il ya plein vol espalion
25 ans au moins 25 morts un soldat
cette vieille carcasse abandonné au bord
des pistes est un breguet 941 un modèle
unique
il n'existe que quatre exemplaires c'est
un appareil qui était conçu pour
atterrir sur des terrains très courts
c'est-à-dire pour atterrir à peu près
n'importe où pour mener des opérations
de proximité
c'est un avion qui a fait la
démonstration de ses capacités en termes
de l' atterrissage et décollage court
mais il avait un gros inconvénient c'est
qu'il ya une semaine
il emmenait pas beaucoup de matériel ou
de personnel d'ailleurs été abandonnée
les avions comme celui-ci marqué par
l'usure du temps et rongé par la rouille
il y en a environ une centaine sur le
tarmac du bourget
tous ont écrit les plus belles pages de
l'histoire de l'aviation mondiale mais
ne vous y trompez pas ici ce n'est pas
un cimetière
chacun de ces avions a reçu son
passeport pour la renaissance wyeth
voilà c'est la toute toute notre
problème est là la corrosion pour
stopper la corrosion et partie 2 sortira
de l'atelier donc les oiseaux quatre ans
oui il sera de neuf donc on aura changé
tous les panneaux j'ai refait tous les
moteurs des trains
is enough le cockpit sauf tout neuf dans
les ateliers le même modèle 4 ans et 18
mille heures de travail plus tard il ne
manque plus que la facture et ce vautour
du 92e escadron de bombardier de
bordeaux traversera une dernière fois la
piste du bourget pour aller rejoindre en
face le musée de l'air pour travailler
nous avons des documents la récupérer
toute la doc technique de l'avion
ensuite il suffit de jus de feuilleter
la dope souvent second sommet janvier
une dizaine d'ouvriers et chaque jour au
chevet de ces grands malades de
l'aviation mais une carrière ne suffira
pas pour résorber la longue liste de or
certains avions attente depuis un temps